[Music]
well hello dear friends uh thank you so
much for joining us today for our
program I'd like to know question and
answer program where uh you participate
because you send us your questions and
we do everything possible to answer
those questions online as well as on our
television channels uh I want I want to
give you the address where you can send
us your questions it's an electronic
address you'll see it on the screen TVM
tv.org
TVM
tv.org we have uh many very good
questions today and we want to get right
into the program I'm here with David
Salasar who who is in charge of the
Spanish work here at Secrets unsealed uh
and I'm wondering if you could have a
word of prayer to ask the Lord to bless
our study together amen let's pray
Pastor Heavenly Father we are so
thankful that we can come once again to
your throne of grace to to receive and
ask the holy spirit so that we may be
able to understand and open the sacred
pages of your scriptures to receive the
truth and the word that is in it for us
I pray that you will help us to also
give answers that are according to your
scripture and that the answers given
today may bring a clear understanding
and bring people closer to you as we
desire this to be the object of this
program we pray for this in Jesus name
amen amen amen okay what question do we
have on the docket all right pastor bour
we have this question today that comes
from Frankie and is a question that uh
seems to be very important and one that
I think requires a lot of Investigation
in a sense let's look at this question
it says I have been studying the 2300
day Prophecy with someone else and he
used tarious caar Reign to explain Jesus
was optied in the Autumn of ad27 at the
end of the 69 weeks he said that Jesus
was baptized in the 15th year reign of
tavarious caar and tavarious Cesar began
his reign in ad2 so he's adding 15 years
of tar Cesar to the 12th the start of
his Reign coming up with a year Jesus
was anointed baptized in
ad27 the problem I have with this is
when you look this up the historical
fact states that tarious Cesar began his
Reign from 14 ad to 37 ad the 14 ad date
is two years too late to fit Jesus
baptism in the Autumn of 27 ad now it
this is true that then Jesus baptism
would be in the Autumn of 029 and not
ad27 this would also mean that this
whole 2300 day prophecy will become like
Fallen dominoes how do you explain this
could this be explained this way to fit
the prophecy
correctly okay there are several things
that we need to say about this number
one uh the date of 27 ad was very
carefully researched by those who
proclaimed the 1844 message uh by
William Miller and his fellow uh workers
you know there were some very very
well-instructed individuals in his day
who accepted the 27 ad date M uh over
and above that um the date of the
baptism of Jesus is disputed there are
some that say it happened in 27 others
say that it happened in 29 mhm uh
because uh it's it's not absolutely
certain uh in the literature that um you
know the date when tiberious Caesar
began to rain that's the whole issue uh
so how do we solve this issue how can we
for certain say that Jesus was baptized
in ad27 and not ad 29 well there's
another way that we can look at this and
that is not by trying to determine
the ending point but the beginning Point
mhm of the 70
weeks now 457 BC is Rock Solid in
history in fact there's a book uh that
is called the chronology of Ezra
7 um but written by wood and Horn two
Scholars of the Adventist Church where
they show from the elephantine papyri
from history and from the biblical text
that the decree was given yeah in
457 BC in the Autumn mhm they proved
that beyond a shadow of a doubt what
does that mean we go from 457 the from
the Autumn of
BC
forward uh 483 years right the 69 weeks
the first 69 weeks the first 69 weeks
mhm where does that take US 27 ad mhm so
you don't have to depend only on the
ending point when it's
disputed the beginning point is not
disputed yeah which means that it has to
be 27 ad now here's the significant
Point not only does history and uh
archaeology and scripture prove that
457 BC is the date but it also the Bible
also proves that it was in the Autumn
mhm how do we understand that Jesus was
baptized in the Autumn which means that
you would have to go from the Autumn of
457 BC to the Autumn to the Autumn of 27
ad MH now how do we know that Jesus was
baptized in the Autumn it's very
simple because from 27 ad to 28 ad is
one year to 29 ad is 2 years years to 30
ad is 3
years to the
spring of
31 because Jesus died in the Passover
time and the middle of we is three and a
half years so it says he would die in
the middle of the week right so just
because the date of tiberious Caesar is
disputed whether it's 27 or 29 is not
relevant to the issue because there's
another way of proving mhm that Christ
was baptized in 27
ad um another point that I would like to
mention is that uh there's a really good
scholar of the Adventist Church uh who
taught at the Seminary Gerard
dste he wrote a short article I think
it's maybe three or four pages on the
issue of the date of the crucifixion and
the day of the baptism the date of the
baptism of Christ and um you know I
haven't asked him for permission but I
don't think that he would be opposed uh
to me sharing it with with those who are
watching the program if you would like
to uh get this article I'll be glad to
send it to you
electronically um you know it's not for
commercial purposes it's so that you can
see the arguments that he uses to show
that uh uh the date for tiberious Caesar
is solid MH and so uh that is available
and uh that's basically all I have to
say about Noor I think you have answered
the question so well but you know just
to add to that I believe it is important
that we take the Bible as our foundation
for everything
chronological events uh when something
in history does not match the Bible you
know because the an analex of the
history or a historian seems to contct
the Bible I do believe that we need to
remember that the Bible is the
infallible word of God and we are to put
our trust in the Bible not in men we
know also that history can be changed in
a way one one way or the other by those
that are writing the history and not
necessarily those that live in in that
time so we have to keep that in mind and
I believe this is why it's important to
keep our chronological views in the
Bible and use that as our foundation as
well and I know that we want to prove
everything sometimes with the historical
events and what history says us but
sometimes certain elements require us to
have that faith and say I believe the
word of God above what men may say
otherwise
right okay well I hope that this uh
discussion has been helpful in answering
this particular question let's go to our
next question which comes to us from
Jude Jude H in the country of Kenya we
have a lot of followers in Africa amen
get lots of questions from African
countries uh actually he has four
questions and we're not going to be able
to address probably all of them here uh
in the time that we have left but let's
uh give it a whirl he wrote hello
everyone in the panel I am Jude Mugo
from Kenya I have been blessed by your
program and now I am dedicated to
reading the Bible and spirit of Prophecy
Bible amen hallelujah praise the Lord uh
I have come across various challenging
quizzes Which I would like you to help
me get the
meaning so uh the first question is in
Colossians 1 and verse
27 and the question is what is the
meaning of the phrase Christ in you the
hope of
glory uh so what is the meaning of that
expression Christ in you the hope of
glory that's the first question okay the
first question Christ in you the hope of
glory well we understand that Christ
literally cannot come in in our hearts
it's not like he comes literally into us
but what he promis would do for us is
that he will sent his Spirit to come
into our minds into our hearts into our
experience so that means that when we
receive the spirit of God we receive
Christ we're receiving Christ we're
receiving the holy spirit in our lives
that experience that power of of of the
Holy Spirit which represents Christ
comes to gives us not only his
righteousness as a imputed experience
but also as an imparted experience
allows us to have that power to obey
that victory that comes through the
power of Christ without Christ and
without his holy spirit we will not be
able to really keep the law we could try
you know we could try to do right things
but we not be able to really live uh
live in a in a way of of harmony with
God or or have that desire to do the
right thing but when Christ comes in us
through the Holy Spirit through the
influence of of the holy spirit in our
hearts we can then have that power to
have that victory that life of following
the steps and have the log written in
our hearts so that is the hope of glory
the hope that we can receive today
obviously the the ultimate Glory will be
in the uh Santi in the experience of
glorification of our bodies when we're
before God but the process starts here
and starts in our experience today as
vessels of Christ as vessels of the Holy
Spirit uh you know it's interesting the
Bible speaks about us being in Christ
and Christ being in US yes yeah us being
in Christ deals with
justification in other words we are in
Christ when we're baptized right Christ
takes all of our sins and places them in
the sanctuary and uh he um becomes our
righteousness but then that is followed
by Christ in US exactly which is
sanctification right and I have a couple
quotations here from the spirit prophecy
on the meaning of uh you know Christ in
you the hope of glory maybe I can read
just one um messages to Young People
page 142 says pure and undefiled
religion is not a
sentiment but the doing of Works of
Mercy and
Love by the way that's based on James
127 this religion is necessary to health
and happiness it enters the polluted
Soul Temple and with a scorge drives out
the sinful
Intruders taking the throne it
consecrates all by its presence
Illuminating the heart with bright with
the bright beams of the son of
righteousness it opens the windows of
the Soul heavenward letting in the
sunshine of God's loveh with it comes
Serenity and composure physical mental
and moral strength
increase because the atmosphere of
Heaven as a living acting agency fills
the
soul Christ is formed within the hope of
glory amen so it's dealing with
sanctification it's becoming ever and
ever more like Christ Christ in you of
Glory uh it's kind of like the Apostle
Paul how do we be how how do is Christ
in us he he's in us through a study of
his word Thy word have I hid in my heart
that I might not sin against thee uh so
you know it's not that Jesus jumps into
us you know we speak about Jesus being
in us right well you know uh it's not
that he physically jumps in us it's the
fact that he controls us through his
word he he enters us through his word if
I could just read this I know that
you're going to mention something
additional but Ellen White wrote we
receive God word as food for the soul
amen through the same evidence by which
we receive bread as food for the
body so how does Christ become part of
us it's by God's word by taking his word
not him by jumping in us but by his word
bread supplies the need of our nature We
Know by experience that it produces
Blood and Bone and brain apply the same
test of the Bible amen when its
principles have actually become the
elements of the character what has been
the result
so Christ in you the hope of glory means
uh Christ developing his character in us
through his word until um until the day
when Jesus comes and we'll say Lo we
have waited for him and he will save us
that's right pastor and you know it's
interesting to know you mentioned there
uh eating eating the food eating the you
know that that word of God and Christ
has said that you are to eat my body but
he meant eat his words his teachings
make them part of your life and and you
know Galatians 2:20 says I am crucified
with Christ nevertheless I live yet not
I but Christ liveth in me and the life
which I now live in the flesh notice how
we live that life in Christ in us I live
by the faith of the Son of God who loved
me and gave himself for me so it's an
experience of living by faith that
living of accepting his righteousness in
our lives having that power to have
victory that is the C of Glory you know
sometimes when you have a child somebody
will say you know I see a lot of his
father in him
exactly that is true it doesn't mean
that the father has jumped in him no it
means that by beholding his father he
becomes much like his father and so
that's a Divine principle you know I
have so many young people come and say
Pastor B how do I overcome sin and I
always ask them what are you listening
to and what are you watching exactly and
because that's where you win or you lose
the battle uh and and uh so I I hope
that that answers this particular
questions there's uh one other I think
we have time for this one yeah also in
Colossians 2 verse n what is the meaning
of uh that in Christ was the godhead
Bly what do we mean by C Christ uh you
know having the divine nature
bodily well you know if we just compare
it with
um notice verse uh in Colossians 1:19
just so that you know compared to that
it says for it please the father that in
him in Christ should all fullness dwell
so when Paul speaks there in chapter 2
verse uh verse n speaking of Jesus in
him in Christ dwelled the fullness of
the godhead bodily it's speaking of
how in Christ was
manifested the will of the father was
manifested the thoughts of the Father
the exercise of the father was done by
Christ in other words he com he
fulfilled everything that the father had
in mind Christ fulfilled and in in not
only in the work that he did for in for
saving Humanity but even before that
Christ was the one that created all
things and all things for by him were
made that meant that even though the
father is the architect Christ is the ex
the Builder the one that made things
possible so in Christ the fullness of
God the fullness of the Father the
fullness of the holy spirit is embodied
it was given for us for Humanity for us
to understand the the will of God what
was the purpose of God and that's what
he came to reveal to us the father was
revealed to the son yeah because Jesus
according to the New Testament MH is God
in human flesh right the beginning was
the word the word was with God the Word
was God he was in the beginning with God
all things were made through him and
without him nothing was made that was
made so so Jesus was in the beginning
mhm fully God yeah and then verse 14
says
that the word was made flesh and dwelt
Among Us yeah Jesus is one person with
two Natures a divine nature yes and a
human nature and the amazing thing is
that in a derived sense the Bible says
that we can inherit the divine nature
other words we can have for our human
nature the aid of the divine nature yes
which is given to us through the
renewing of our mind the Apostle Paul
says once again we come to the issue
of what we're putting in our mind that's
where the battle is won or the Battle Is
Lost what are you watching what are you
listening to you know what kind of music
are you listening to is it sensual music
are you watching movies that defile your
soul you know we
are physically what we eat through our
mouth yeah we are spiritually what we
eat through our eyes and through our
ears yeah yeah you're right is also
important to know that when Paul writes
this you know is speaking of Christ also
in um you know his in heaven he has
received that newness or or has received
the the confirmation of a glorified body
so if even in the presence physically
speaking Christ already has the fullness
of the Father the the holy spirit in in
the new body if you will so even even
sort of links us to that aspect as well
in that little sense you know yeah you
know I want to read just a few verses
here as time winds down um Jesus is the
express image of his
father that's what we find in Hebrews
the book of Hebrews it says he was the
expressed image of his person you know
when when the Bible speaks about uh the
image of God in us it uses the word icon
Aon Aon but when it refers to Jesus the
word that is
translated
is so the express image is the
word in other words the son has the
identical car character to the father
and this helps us understand uh John
chapter
14 uh and uh verse 7 Jesus says to his
disciples if you had known me you would
have known my father also and from now
on you know him and have seen him
how did they see him yeah through Jesus
mhm and it continues saying in verse 8
Philip said to him Lord show us the
father and it is sufficient for us Jesus
said to him have I been with you so long
and you yet you have not known me
Phillip he who has seen me has seen the
father so how can you say show us the
father do you not believe that I am in
the father and the father in
me not speaking that they jump into each
other literally course by the way the
words that I speak to you I do not speak
of my own authority but the father who
dwells in me does the works believe me
that I am in the father and the father
in me or else believe me for the sake of
the works themselves so Jesus is the
express image of the father he's 100%
God and has the identical character of
God but he's he has his own
individuality in other words he's not
the same person he doesn't jump into
another person right he actually has the
same uh character uh that the father has
and Pastor you know a lot of times
people have
question the Divinity of Christ you know
there's religions that are based on the
fact that they deny Christ as uh fully
God you know they think has some sort of
inition or was created or whatever but
they don't understand that when the
Bible speaks of his eternal you know
existence and the Divinity of Christ
being God With Us and and this is why
Paul emphasizes this and I think that uh
even today a lot of folks are
misunderstanding this nature of Christ
this experience of he been God and also
being human and so with this the enemy
has done a lot of confusion created a a
lot of you know ill thinking about who
God is and who the Christ is and even
who the holy spirit is but we need to
just limit ourselves to accept as the
Bible speaks of who they are how the
godhead is the Father the Son and the
Holy Ghost or the Holy Spirit three
persons three individuals who are one in
purpose one in in mind in thinking in in
in in you know what they want to do for
mankind and for for universe as a whole
so this is why the fullness of all three
in Christ present the fact that they are
connected they're all working in one
Accord the bottom line is we'll never be
able to understand fully the Incarnation
yeah that's a it's a mystery a mystery
both Ellen White and the Bible speak of
it as a mystery the mystery of godliness
God was manifested in human flesh how do
you understand that there that there are
two Natures in one person yeah I mean
you can Bogle your mind for eternity and
you'll never be able to solve it because
you the revealed things are for us but
the secret things belong to the Lord so
let's not try and delve in it like you
were saying let's trust what the Bible
says amen the Bible says that Jesus was
one person with two Natures a Divine and
a human nature and we have to leave it
at that amen and we if we depend on God
we can become inheritors of the divine
nature and we can overcome of course in
a derived sense not in an absolute sense
thank you for joining us God bless you
amen
[Music]